how many errors are in this video about
Beyonce's lemonade Beyonce Giselle
Knowles Carter is a Grammy winning
singer songwriter dancer and perfume
creator born in 1981 in Houston Texas
she rose to fame as a member of the girl
group Destiny's Child with her childhood
friend Kelly Rowland and Michelle
Williamson in 2003 she became a solo
artist and released dangerously in love
this album won four Grammy Awards and
sold 2 million copies in April 2016
Beyonce released her seventh solo album
lemonade as a film on HBO and an album
on tidal the visual album's spoken word
in Toulouse were written by Beyonce and
her grandmother the fat Beyonce uses in
the holdup video features the word foxy
Cleopatra based on her character's name
in her first feature film many lyrics
reference being cheated on and have
caused controversy due to Beyonce's
marriage to rap icon J's in the fourth
song on the album sorry Beyonce alludes
to her man be unfaithful with Katy with
the good hair there were nine errors in
this video tell us how many you caught
in the comments below what should we put
next